[Music]
and see nathan and
and uh
and laugh
we're all just laughing and joking
around right before take yesterday we
were shooting something up on the bridge
where like the reaver ships are coming
and it's just really tense a moment and
we're all petrified and we're already
rolling two seconds before josh calls
action nathan makes a crack
we all crack up we're like crap okay i
gotta straighten up my face
nathan has the most inexhaustible energy
for
entertaining
that um
that i've i've i've been around and is
really really funny
hello
what's my life
um
it's getting to be a better movie for
zoey
he is constantly distracting nathan is
quite a distraction
it's all lies
you know what it's so tough sometimes
some of the days we have
if alan says one more thing to me i'm
going to explode
jesus christ he's been drinking again
i told you about this
it's good to get that off my chest
[Music]
nathan
[Music]
and his hair
he's a hair actor uh he knows it am i
gonna have to pull it out youtube
oh it was open to harry's shirt
we were doing some hair flinging
uh and that's all i have to say about
nathan who's in there
[Music]
you this is my interview selfish
i love nathan he's so cool
oh
jesus
i love him
he's my captain listen adam yes sir i
want you to consider
for this next take
less
no
wait act more
no
stop let's see the final frame or
just get it right okay
uh nathan yes are you clear on the
pickup
no
i was joking around
okay well what have we learned today
josh's boss
i'm on tv
marker
it's a movie are you taping
i ain't looking for help from on high
so
spine's intact just give me a bandage
[Laughter]
he's not the plucky hero oh [ __ ]
that was close
hey what are you guys doing
making out blow it kevin
captain
captain
look up chad
god damn it this one's locked
i ain't waiting for the alliance to
choose mine
[Applause]
my cartridge fell out of my gun
sir are you sure you don't want me to
dance the marina or something what
are you going to say some of my favorite
word
can't leave her in that storage locker
one more time
[Laughter]
selfish son of a [ __ ] separate from
riddling you with holes doctor
one
[ __ ]
keep going
we'll sleep easy
because we're off your boat justices
oh well you see that right you see it
you see that
would you turn would you turn do you
want to fly this thing
would you pull over is that what you saw
what are you doing i will start mine
damn it i don't need a back spaceship
driver get out of the way
all right that's it fine you want to fly
[ __ ] pie
i feel my bum okay
what does that have
say graceful when i want to i have no
i can to
doubt
what aren't you doing crap
some of our jobs are more interesting
than others
summer
[Applause]
where are we headed
serenity's east of us nestled in the
lower lines
rats
where are we headed surrenders east of
us nestled in the reload
no hang a left we get to have in a new
power new flowers how people if your's
time
y'all were listening in i take
y'all we're watching i take it
yes
do you see his fight
no trap
last one again you knew he was going to
leave
we had been never
you knew he was going to leave
i've never been but a waste station of
those two and
don't [ __ ] tell me what the goddamn
dude
my ship the god damn dude
sorry
um
what's my line
ready to get off this garbage heap and
back to your civilized life i uh
you [ __ ] up
i've seen so much death
jane
you and wash hoist up that cannon mount
i want to go
[ __ ] [ __ ]
action
get these bodies together
we got time for grave digging zoey this
time we're going to rope them together
five or six will i want laid out on the
nose of our ship are you insane good
book front and center he's our friend we
should honor him
find that kid who's taking a dirt nap to
baby jesus we need a hood ornament jane
try not to steal too much of their [ __ ]
wash
start with the part where jane gets
knocked out by a 90 year old
man
oh man what
watch me soar
or watch how i source actually the line
they just float out there sending out
rave reading parties
there's a blast doors
then you shut them and you need to
i can rig them so they won't reopen once
they close then you shut them and you
hide into like we have to [ __ ]
there's a bathroom right now
at last we can retire and give up this
[ __ ] [ __ ]
i sound like you
[Music]